question for you
when it comes down to two names we got
powell which is
obviously the fed chairman of the phone
and then we have
yellen okay which she sometimes forgets
and she thinks she still has powell's
job right she still thinks that's her
job right
which of those two is creating the
biggest havoc
and which of those two has the most
influence on what direction
rates could go to and what direction
real estate could go to the next 12 24
36 months okay so we should also mention
janet yellen used to be the fed chair i
didn't think she was a very good course
i didn't think she was a good fed chair
but she used to be the fed chair
and what janet yellen's job now is
treasury secretary besides signing the
money that comes out we you know the
treasury secretary
signs the cash that you get is janet
yellen
sells the president's agenda so what's
her job to do
is not what's good for you what's good
for me what's good for people listening
it is to sell the president's agenda
let's understand that right
so she's a salesperson right now she had
different responsibilities as a fed
chair
but it is crazy and maddening to hear
this woman
talk about the wealth gap that's out
there and wealth inequality
when her and ben bernanke created it
because what they decided to do
was now who knows what the motivation
was it might have been pure motivation
but what they decided to do was they
took rates to these
unbelievably low levels begin
quantitative easing
and by taking rates to where you were
punished for savings
they gave us as we all know tina tina
which stands for there is no alternative
and bernanke used to call this the
wealth effect
and what he said was if we stop people
from saving and force them to all put
their money collectively it's the same
thing that
the reddit boards are doing okay it's
just on a grander scale
it's no different than the reddit meme
stocks except they did it
wall street banks it's the exact same
thing except now
they've got the whole country doing it
because i'm going to punish you for
saving
i'm going to let you earn less than one
percent in your savings
and the only place you could put your
money is in the stock market
and by doing so everybody did that the
stock market has been on what
kind of a ride since then we all know
okay so
when you see that occur by the way folks
i want you to hear
can you say that one more time say the
last 30 seconds one more time what
they've done
this very important they punished you to
save your money to put into market
market say that one more time
so by taking the the benefit of saving
money
people used to say i could plan for my
retirement because i could put my money
in the bank safely get
four percent five percent six month
market cd saving account you have many
options
that's safe i can plan for america now i
can never retire like that
okay i can't do that and what would
happen to those people
is that they were forced people that
shouldn't be taking risk grandma
was now taking risks and putting them in
the stock market
fortunately because everybody did it it
created growth in the stock market as we
have seen for the last 12 years
right however here's the big point is
that
not everybody's in the stock market so
this is what created the haves and
have-nots
to a much more exacerbated way because
now people
50 of families were able to go in the
stock market 50 of families benefited
those 50 that were left behind were left
way behind
and it is sickening to hear her talk
about it as if she had nothing to do
with it
because her and ben bernanke created
this mm-hmm
it's the wall street versus mainstream
approach right there wall street versus
main street approach exactly right
so you're not a fan of yellen or what
she's doing i think she apologizes
i don't i don't think that she you know
well currently again she's a salesperson
so you know you always have to be a
little leery of salespeople because they
all have their agenda right mm-hmm
um what would you say to somebody who
says well barry's a salesperson
he's got an agenda he's in real estate
well every individual has their own
agenda right
where you where you stand depends on
where you sit right so you have you have
your point of view and everybody's
trying to do that
i'm i'm offering an opinion which is
just that it's an opinion that's the way
it should be taken right it's not
uh there's some things that are factual
that some of the data we spoke about is
factual but
in this case it's an opinion i don't
think she did a very good job as
as the fed chair as well um i think that
she had chances where she could have
raised rates
and did not do so i think that i think
that the fed gets
frightened because who wants to be named
as the fed chair
who let the economy tank and that's the
problem jay powell who you mentioned has
right now
because when he tried in 2013 to taper
the market went into a tantrum and he
backed off now that was taking the fed's
balance sheet from 4.3 trillion to 3.8
trillion
and they said can't do it now the fed's
balance sheet is eight
trillion dollars that's that's a scary
thought when you think about that so
let's let's see there's a trillion
dollar balance let's do this this is fun
because everybody is listening they're
hearing trillion trillion trillion so
listen
if i said to you hey let's do a business
deal cash deal and i said patrick
i'm gonna pay you cash a hundred
thousand dollars cash i bring a brief
big suitcase in i open up the suitcase
and it's hundred dollar bills
it's very anti-climactic it's a
four-inch stack
a million dollars is a 40-inch stack
of hundred dollar bills if you could
stack hundred-dollar bills this high
it's a million bucks a billion takes you
to the empire state building twice
eight trillion if i stack them up one on
top of each other and then tilted it on
its side it'd go from here
to california and back 5400 miles
that's what eight trillion dollars is in
hundred dollar bills it is an
enormous sum of money and we get blind
to it
because we constantly hear it and we
become immune
yeah so so then the question becomes
then the question becomes when
we're talking about interest rates how
likely and
how soon do you predict the rates could
go up to six percent
can it happen if yes how soon can that
happen okay so so let's understand
um there's a few things occurring right
now so i'm going to answer that question
but let's give some background so i do
think there might be some policy change
coming in
august so it's we think i think that
when we get the jackson hole meeting by
the fed that has in the past
been where they changed policy now we
heard from the saint louis fed president
bullard we also just heard
from um another fed president who
was talk oh uh we were talking we were
talking about
the fact that the housing market might
be overheating and when we
oh this was the boston fed president um
i'll get in a minute the boston freight
president talked about the
housing market overheating so what
they're saying is that
the fed should stop buying
mortgage-backed securities
eric rosengren is who it was yes so the
two of them now have been talking about
the
the market overheating so i think come
the 26th
27th 28th of august at that meeting they
may say that the fed's going to begin to
taper their purchase of mortgage-backed
securities
how much are they buying well they lie
they said they were buying 40 billion
we started calling them out on it so
what did they do they removed the data
from the new york fed.org so you
couldn't find it that easily
recently they purchased about 80 billion
in a month so now they change their
language to 40 billion
to 100 to at least 40 billion a month
but it's closer to 100 billion
a month that they're buying so they're
buying the market it's called yield
curve control we haven't really done it
since the 1940s
but they pegged yields and they said we
want to keep it here
think about how crazy it is inflation
erodes the buying power
the inflation rate right now let's call
it three and a half percent is the core
rate stripping out food and energy
the 10-year treasury yields one and a
half percent so i'm getting one and a
half but my money's eroding at three and
a half percent that should never happen
how sustained how long can that be
sustainable it shouldn't be sustainable
but when the fed is buying so much in
treasuries to keep and suppress that
yield down
artificially if inflation's three and a
half you've got to make a spread on that
it's got to be four and a half
that's where the 10-year treasury should
be with three and a half percent in
places now i think inflation will abate
i think inflation will come to i know
the fed loves transitory there are
certain things that will stick
but look patrick if you take a look at
some of the reasons why the the numbers
in cpi went up and the numbers in the pc
personal consumption expenditures a
different inflation report that the fed
loves
the reason why they went up is the
reopening because what really went up
is uh sporting event sales went up ten
percent hotels went up nine percent
airlines went up ten percent and then
you have the chip shortage issue
so it made uh vehicles go up five
percent and compute i'm sorry ten
percent of you and computers go five
percent
because of that it made a big jump in
cpi but those sectors combined
only represent seven percent of the
economy the other 93
only went up three tenths of a percent
so we have some inflation it's not as
high as being stated
it will calm down but rates will never
go to six percent never go to six
percent no at least not
while i'm around i don't think because
what has to cause that is you need
enormous inflation
technology is advancing so much it is
keeping costs lower
artificial intelligence robotics
technology in general will continue to
make things cheaper and cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper
and in addition to that the supply of
labor that we have is pretty strong
we're in a position that if jobs become
eliminated
you're going to see costs continue to be
pressured lower and also global
globalization has kept so so arthur
laffer whom uh
i love him you know who he is i spoke to
him uh was it last week i
last week we had him on or something two
weeks ago i said that what's your
biggest concern
what do you stand with inflation he says
i'm not at all worried about inflation
because he said the leading indicator of
inflation to me is
gold prices and go gold prices and gold
prices haven't moved and i asked
danielle and danielle's like no
inflation is here
there's nothing we can do about it it's
going to continue to go up where do you
stand with inflation
love art danielle's right inflation will
be some ex
some inflation is going to be sticky
okay some especially on the wages that's
the stickiest
are we going to go into hyperinflation
mode or no no no we're not going to do
that although there's a lot of money
sloshing around but no hyperinflation
and and you can't just go buy gold
anymore
because you know the boomer rocks of
gold used to be a good indicator
and since the beginning of time they say
one ounce of gold should buy one fine
man suit right
and that probably is still true today so
with gold at a little over 1700
an ounce i think that you know that
still holds true but gold isn't the only
indicator because of the rise of
cryptocurrencies
so if you don't believe in fiat money
because the printing press
you had the alternative gold before but
now you also have the alternative crypto
so gold if it were not for crypto
gold would be at a much higher level
all right so you're not too worried
about inflation you don't think rates
are going to get to six percent anytime
soon
concerned about inflation but i do think
it will abate and i think some of it was
going to be sticky and stay
all right but here's the thing that we
have to understand is that debt and i
know most people don't get this and this
i'm going to give a hat tip to one of my
mentors lacie hunt was one of those
brilliant minds out there
so he taught me this and showed me this
but debt
we know this every time in history and
everywhere in the world the higher the
debt the lower the rates
because what debt does is it drives
economic activity
slower which prevents inflation if you
have a family that wants to buy a car
when we were kids he used to have a
piggy bank he used to have a piggy back
you'd save up you break the piggy bank
you go buy it great as adults who wants
to do that we want instant gratification
we want it now yep
so we use credit to take a future
purchase and make it today
if a family wants to buy a car they go
out and they buy that car today using
credit using debt
and it creates economic activity
economic activity what that will do is
the dealership the manufacturer the
sales part they all make money to spend
money
but it has a short life what sticks is
now that family has a thousand dollar a
month debt for the next
60 months which means they could buy
less and it's the same thing with our
economy
cares act one and two was 2.8 trillion
dollars
that was in march and april of 2020 by
october the economy was already slowing
the gdp for the united states was 4.3 in
in the fourth quarter was 0.4 it was all
front loaded
and i the reason why there's such panic
to generate these additional stimulus
plans right now
is because they know that the sugar rush
will
begin to slow okay all right so we'll
see what happened i mean obviously it's
great to hear different perspectives but
you know the audience has to make up
their minds
uh the one part that was very
uh eye opening was to say in 0708 when
the whole michael berry brick short
happened there was 3.7 million
inventory today's a million that's a
very big difference an indicator because
you got almost way too much and then 12
million increase in the uh
family uh households you're talking
about 12 million from what from 160
million to 128 million is a number give
or take so
and patrick remember birth rates stayed
low
from 1973 to 1979
which means you did not have the influx
of people coming yeah
and and now things have turned a little
bit because the exact opposite what's
the generation they're saying that's
bigger than boomers is it gen x or is it
millennials millennials are bigger than
boomers now 80 million versus 76 million
so
if that's the case you're saying real
estate's gonna continue to rise over the
next few years
let's hope it doesn't get too far ahead
of itself but let's say it this way
it should be well supported so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]